yeah a new video black against an
international master from this odd Tina
right yeah doesn't have a name in there
nims oh and by now i already am posted a
video to mention that i'm working on a
book on the names Oh amongst others okay
the news & bogel Knight f3 is a bit of a
rare set up in the Samish but damn it
suits you can you can do it it's not
it's not terrible yeah
yeah this is not this is not a porn
blunder I can I can take on d for now
but white is got them quite strong
strong diagonals then for for the
bishops so I'm not sure that I want to
take black can also play some waiting
moves this is not strictly a theoretical
position but it's it's close this idea
is very much known 92 only the move a 3
years some somewhat uncommon in this
position quite often this happens
without wide having played a three years
l like a cm almost a whole move up
compared to other lines of course the
position is quite closed so you cannot
really say it it's a big east remove
that black has been has been gifted okay
so white is not moving not quite sure
why but d5 sm is a possibility i played
a somewhat premature maybe Queenie seven
so that the normal normal square night e
seven is not available
yeah the idea is to take care play
Bishop to you for I try to get some play
against the sea pawn this maybe provokes
m2m to advance the porn
yep not quite sure what white should
should play now I'm intending to take
and play let's say rook c8
uh-huh this is an interesting woof
didn't didn't expect that mmm I just go
rook c8 what is idea we need threatening
to take it takes the 60 I must I must do
something here I could play Knight a5 on
the other hand why not 95 attack the sea
porn directly yeah come on let's play
greedy chess attack the spawn I don't
really know what what is doing now about
the pawn retreating yeah this is a very
very modest solution ok I think I can
flick in this move threatening e4 and
then decide how to continue ok so let's
say C takes see takes rook c8 how does
he protect the C porn maybe Queenie to
and I did capture first to make sure I
actually have a simple on to attack a
play rock choc people can play d5 and
close it up and hear the sea poorness is
really attacked so yeah if i go here
it's a it's an exchange right or or 94
okay this device is really is still good
good move if i take the rook he will i
repair his structure hmm yeah it's an
exchange but Nick one I don't take it I
could take I could take it probably and
it's not bad but this I can just pile up
on the sea por now Roxy 7 rook c8 I mean
okay you can they can do that but what
is what are these pieces doing okay wait
wait wait is maybe intending f4 but FYI
can go 97 this is lots not a problem
takes I played 95
I want to have the possibility to
recapture with the f porn right down c5
the next move okay this didn't really
help how to regroup p.m.
don't don't really see how to how to
improve in this position
yeah it's the kind of position where
white cannot do much but I don't really
see how I prove myself
bring this night 2h7 to control g5
trying to close it close the position
here and he's protecting all this on the
other side this is some of this annoying
okay so maybe I should have taken the
exchange well after what seven you
always know what what you should have
done at this most of the time you know
what you what you should have done
time warning what do we add game I
really don't understand what was
happening him honestly I mean he really
played some some weird stuff but I
really am I couldn't really take my
completely overlooked that this was so
saying Jack Jack I got i could win out
time I think it's very slow
yeah wyd got 20 28 hundredths of a
second and while I offered once nothing
for offer any more drawers at the end in
the time scramble I loose on time but
this was weird I mean okay maybe I
should just I just just take let's just
take the exchange I mean he does this
all was a very very very nice I didn't
want to correct his his pawn structure
here I can also take on d4 I mean this
is very good for black d5 was was worth
very good I mean what else but still I
didn't want to want to take the exchange
but yeah maybe it isn't it isn't so
great after this some others look at it
it just protects you for and you don't
really make any progress here I probably
must take but how to how to play now
and then a five year this is may be
right I can break up the pawns in this
way yeah maybe this way I mean that why
doesn't have enough for the exchange
this much is clear but I didn't want to
repair his structure so I went for for
this 95 but the problem is after he
plays Queenie to is protecting this four
on four times and I can only attack it
four times and I cannot increase the
pressure anymore and after this this is
the only point of attack I I don't have
any other pawn pawn breaks something and
he's got play on the King side it's
probably around equal again maybe the
the the clearest solution I was after
after this here after this rook move
just to take the pawn this was possible
it's not it's not clear what white white
is doing now it's a pawn down and and I
have got all kinds of ideas knight c6 35
and so on yeah this is just the best
move probably and I've got all pieces on
the best possible squares the rook both
roofs are good and everything's
attacking yeah this is just simple 96
was looking nice but d5 was really a
good practical answer yeah thanks for
watching